The second common architecture for
Internet services is referred to
as functionally heterogeneous.
In these kinds of architectures,
different nodes are designated to
perform certain functions, or even to
see in the particular types of requests.
For instance, the request may be divided
among the servers based on the request
content, such as when the requests
are divided based on the alphabetical
order of the requested file name.
Or for a service such as eBay,
servers may be designated to perform
browsing requests versus buying or
bidding requests.
With this design, it is still
possible to have all of the data in
some distributed, shared file system and
accessible to all of the nodes.
But if the functions are somehow
designated to be executed only
on some subset of the node,
then it is possible that not all
of the data, not all of the state,
will be necessary to be made available
across all nodes in the system.
So there's some optimization
opportunities there.
Clearly, one benefit of this approach is
that every single node in this system
is more specialized for some of
the tasks that it performs, or for
some of the state that it needs to
serve, and therefore, it is more likely
that it will take advantage of some
benefits like caching and locality.
There are also some obvious trade-offs.
The first one is that the front end
will now need to be more complex
because it will need to parse sufficient
portion of the incoming request so
as to be able to figure out which
one of the underlying nodes
this particular request
should be passed to.
Second, the overall management of these
systems becomes more complex when nodes
fail or when request rates increase,
and we need to add more machines,
it is important to know what
kinds of machines to add.
How to configure those machines,
what types of requests or
tasks are those machines
suppose to be designated for.
Also even if something changes in
the workload pattern and all of a sudden
there are more requests of a certain
kind, then we have to reconfigure this.
We can't just redirect those access of
requests to some of the other nodes if
they are not capable of processing
those kind of actions or
serving that kind of data.
So that may even be the case if
the other nodes are otherwise idling.
The result of that is that it is much
more easy in these kinds of environments
to end up in situations in which
some of the nodes are hotspots, and
then there are long backlogs of pending
requests for those kinds of nodes.